[Musica]
vi parlerò oggi di un viaggio del mio
viaggio verso l'abisso che dal fondo ma
ha portato alla rinascita sono
primatista del mondo di apnea in assetto
variabile e sono diventata atleta a 40
anni
come si diventa atleta 40 anni mi
chiedono in molti
beh nel mio caso è stato facile mi sono
separata
[Applauso]
ho frequentato il mio primo corso
d'apnea ha 36 anni e mi sono subito resa
conto che per migliorare in questo sport
c'è bisogno di tempo per adattare il
corpo alla profondità ed io all'epoca di
tempo ne avevo veramente poco da dea
dedicare almeno ob
ero totalmente assorbita dalla famiglia
e dai figli e solo raramente riuscivo a
fare qualche uscita in mare con gli
amici
eppure sono brava mi dicevo nel 2010
riesco a trasformare un momento negativo
della mia vita in un'opportunità
la forbice di tempo di libertà dai figli
che la separazione mi impone durante il
periodo estivo diventano per me
l'occasione di fare qualche allenamento
più serio detto fatto
mi iscrivo alla mia prima competizione
internazionale ad are in egitto perché
in allenamento avevo già raggiunto la
quota di un record italiano ma problemi
di natura e cultura personale mi
costringono a rinunciare l'anno seguente
tuttavia un allenatore crede in me e la
metamorfosi da atleta della domenica in
atleta comincia e mi ritrovo così
all'improvviso seduta sono panchina
all'interno della stazione di roma
termini in attesa del trenino che mi
avrebbe portato a fiumicino da lì sarei
partita alla volta di kalamata in grecia
per disputare la mia prima gara in
assoluto outdoor di hartner nonché un
mondiale
beh io sapevo quanti metri ero in grado
di scendere sott'acqua
sapevo fin dove ero arrivata ma perché
andare ad ufficializzare un risultato
perché andare a disputare un mondiale
avevo paura ero lì seduta su quella
panchina e fissavo la mia monopinna ed
attratti volevo fuggire volevo andar via
volevo tornare a casa dai miei figli
alla mia famiglia alla mia vita normale
avevo paura del salto nella b
so che stavo per compiere gli
organizzatore del mondiale non mi
avevano neanche ancora comunicato quale
fosse il mio albergo non conoscevo le
regole del gioco
sapevo solo che per centrare il mio
obiettivo avrei avuto un'unica
opportunità non come in allenamento dove
quando sbagli il giorno dopo ci riprovi
avevo paura di fallire
avevo paura di aver lasciato a casa i
miei bambini per essere giudicata da
tutti perché il mio è uno sport
pericoloso e costoso e senza guadagni un
mare di inquietudini mi si affollavano
nella mente
tuttavia c'era qualcosa in me che mi
costringeva a stare lì seduta su quella
panchina e ad aspettare quel trenino ed
era la curiosità la mia anima era a
conoscenza del mio progetto sapeva
intimamente ciò che avrei voluto fare
come donna ero curiosa perché volevo
fare esperienze nuove viaggiare
conoscere le persone con culture
religioni lingue ed usanze diverse come
atleta
ero curiosa di riuscire a ripetere in
gara sotto gli occhi di giudici mondiali
il tuffo
così si chiama la prova della tennista
one shot che già avevo fatto in
allenamento ma in una situazione di
maggiore distensione e tra amici ero
curiosa di riuscire a superare i miei
limiti che solo per caso coincidevano
con limiti da record
ho imparato di me che attraversando la
paura e liberando la curiosità o forza
di volontà carattere e dedizione e la
spinta decisiva che mi ha fatto saltare
su quel treno e andare fino in fondo
allo sogno è stata il coraggio e del
coraggio di esplorare l'abisso mi ha
portato a conoscere le discipline più
estreme dell'apnea il nolimit ed il
variabile dal 2011 ad oggi omologato 6
record italiani e un record del mondo in
quattro discipline diverse ed ho voluto
e dovuto adattarmi a diversi modi di far
apnea
a diverse attrezzature a diversi modi di
pinneggiare passando dalle due pinne
alla monopinna a diversi modi di
respirare e di compensare le orecchie ho
imparato a conoscere parti del mio corpo
di cui non avevo neanche la percezione
il cavo oro faringeo ho imparato a
caricare dell'area in bocca ea gestirla
durante tutta la mia discesa per tenere
le tube di un sacco sempre bene aperte
ho imparato quindi sa muovere bene la
lingua terale a tenere serrata alla
glottide e contemporaneamente aperto il
palato molle amore a muovere bene le mie
mandibole non solo per mangiare e le mie
guance dopo soli tre tuffi in queste
nuove discipline
ho raggiunto meno 100 metri di
profondità 100 metri è il numero
agognato da ogni appresta a tre cifre
dopo qualche allenamento tutte tuttavia
ho uno scontro frontale con la slitta
così si chiama l'attrezzato e mi porta
sott'acqua e quasi perdo l'occhio destro
resto sei mesi a secco ma non mi
scoraggio l'anno successivo omologo tra
i record italiani di cui uno imbattuto
da 26 anni nel 2017 sono già pronta per
il mio record del mondo ma un serio
problema durante un allenamento nonché
la mancanza di uno sponsor
il mio è uno sport di nicchia costoso
soprattutto per garantirmi la sicurezza
di cui necessito mi costringono a
rinunciare psicologicamente sono a terra
o un incidente alle spalle niente soldi
ed un entourage che continuamente mi
ripete che sono grande d'età che sono
madre che è pericoloso e mi chiede
ossessivamente perché io tuttavia ho una
fiducia incrollabile in me stessa
lavoro sodo 5 ora la giorno tutti i
giorni tra palestra piscina e campo di
atletica
non che segue una rigorosissima dieta
e l'estate successiva questa estate ci
riprovo sono di nuovo in acqua ma di
nuovo dopo qualche allenamento o un
grave incidente
ed allora è era giunto il momento di
chiedermi realmente se questa fosse la
mia strada
dopo un periodo di riposo ordinato mi
dai medici tuttavia trovo di nuovo il
coraggio di andare fino in fondo al mio
progetto di toccare l'abisso
e la risposta non tarda e fight to one
la squadra
si sa mai
[Musica]
guardini terzo
forti meters
si pensi
e kimi terzo
[Musica]
anche meters uomini lo stack di testa
e i teenagers
[Musica]
626 conseguiti e di sé conseguiti d'oro
nei sistemi terzo
meeting the furious mt
se vedi percepiti da un ultimi test
[Musica]
katy meters
goian timidezza
temi terzo
qui
[Musica]
a 48 anni sono diventata campionessa del
mondo di apnea in assetto variabile con
meno 115 metri in 3 minuti e 4 secondi e
quasi 13 atmosfere che premono sul mio
corpo e sulle mie orecchie che cosa
provi quando sei da sola laggiù nel
silenzio mi chiedono tutti a il silenzio
dell'abisso vorrei far velo ascoltare è
una cosa così rumorosa che attrae
inesorabilmente la mia attenzione e nel
silenzio che si svolge la mia
performance ed è il silenzio che mi
permette di essere concentrata ed il
contatto con me stessa
per me la parte più difficile del tuffo
e la discesa la slitta mi fa volare a
più di due metri e mezzo al secondo e la
pressione amenta incessantemente sul
corpo e sulle mio ricche
io però mi lascio andare mi lascio
totalmente prendere schiacciare dal mare
non oppongo resistenza
sono totalmente rilassata c'è tuttavia
una parte di me che restano allerta
resto nel qui ed ora o del lavoro da
fare a quelle profondità la narcosi per
una pista è sempre in agguato e non
posso permettermi il lusso di perdere il
focus è finalmente tocco il cappello ma
arrivò al fondo meta del viaggio è fatta
resta solo la sua metà che gioia che
adrenalina che è bello certo ho tanti
metri ancora da notare prima di arrivare
in superficie una colonna infinita
d'acqua pesa sulla mia testa ma io mi
ripeto fiduciosa che il piolo fatto il
più me lo sono già lasciato alle spalle
e quindi mi
detto anche il lusso di sorridere solo
chi ti ama veramente ti aiuta a volare
ed io mi sono amata tanto e mi sono
accorta fortemente che qualcosa e mi era
cambiato quando le voci degli altri mi
sono sembrate solo il fruscio di api
ronzanti e specchiando mi nei loro occhi
mi sono già vista signora degli abissi
grazie
[Musica]